[Música]
más
y
[Música]
puerto sánchez es una pequeña se nadita
a orillas del río paraná
entre lo que es hoy el balneario
thompson y el puerto de la ciudad de
paraná
un pequeño rincón de pescadores donde se
convive entre la naturaleza y otra vez
río sus barrancas
su flora y su fauna autóctona
sus aromas
sus sabores
hacen de este pequeño rincón de
pescadores un lugar único y él
ahí nací yo
ahí crecí alimentada pescado como dicen
algunos
en este pequeño rincón de pescadores se
han inspirado
músicos
poetas escritores
pintores
los más emblemáticos linares cardozo con
su canción de cuna costera inspirado en
nuestra caridad doming ayala y su hijo
de wilkie
jorge mendes
nuestro embajador cultural con canción a
puerto sánchez
hoy traducida a varios idiomas
el inglés
el alemán
para mí
si una canción a puerto sánchez va a
encontrar con un sinnúmero de canciones
ya cual de todas más bonitas
ahora
saben
qué es lo mejor que tiene puertos anchas
lo mejor que tiene este lugar
es su gente
son los pescadores
los costeros que aún preservan
su cultura
sus tradiciones sus raíces
gente
de trabajo
que valora el esfuerzo que respecta a
los mayores
gente humilde
gente digna
cuándo
a mí me decían y así como a mí a muchos
de mis hermanos de mis vecinos
tiramos negro de la costa
alimentado pescado
porque yo sé perfectamente lo que cada
uno de los pescadores debe padecer cada
día para llevar al sustento a su casa
son muy bien carne propia nadie me lo
contó
yo sé de sacrificio que es el trabajo de
la pesca
en verano a la siesta esos soles
buscando tu curas
arrastrando en las citas de carnada
en alguna laguna
con el agua caliente que corre el riesgo
de que el 86 una raya o lo muerde alguna
palometa
al atardecer
los mosquitos
que no te dejan ni encarnar el espinel
vivir sobre salsas
o sobre la canoa que para el caso se
convierte en un pequeño mono ambiente
se trabaja
reparan las herramientas pero hay
también se hace fuego se cocina se come
y se descansa se duerme
baja el río también se complica porque
los espineles se entierran en el lecho
del río y hay que hacer un esfuerzo
enorme para levantarlos para poder
recorrer los en cada recorrido
de escarcha es tremenda te llega a las
manos es horrible
y sustento a casa
por eso me da bronca cuando le regatean
el precio pescado
no tienen ni idea de lo que cuestan las
herramientas de pesca lo que tienen que
invertir un pescador en cada recorrido
no tiene idea lo que cuesta una caja de
anzuelos lo que cuesta un rollo de tanza
ni idea lo que cuesta un par de remos
una canoa y los motores
por ello algo que siempre me molestó
mucho que me ha dolido y me ha dado
bronca
que es cuando nos dicen que nos gusta
inundarnos para que nos regalen chapas y
colchones
cuándo
pasamos día y noche
llenando bolsas con grasa con arena
para rellenar el terraplén
acarreando escombro palos piedras lo que
fuere para evitar que se corta el
terraplén e ingresar a buenas casas que
nos gusta a inundarnos cuando he visto a
mis hermanos tipo térmicos
festibando bolsa desde el río para
rellenar socavones
para sostener ese terraplén
que evita que ingrese el agua a las
viviendas porque no queremos que haya un
solo inundado
porque no queremos que haya un solo
evacuado
y hay otras personas que piensan
que erradicar al costero es la solución
el pescador
de hecho a la primera
a donde estacionar acá no
no está fácil trasladar al costero
y ojo que en alguna oportunidad la idea
de erradicar nos no fue precisamente
para prevenir las inundaciones sino que
a alguien se le ocurrió que un complejo
de cabañas en ese hermoso balcón al río
sería de gran atractivo turístico
y la gente de puerto sánchez a donde iba
a parar pero saben que para eso también
apuntamos y para eso también los
plantamos y todas esas vivencias
me hicieron dar cuenta y nos hicieron
dar cuenta
que no se valora
y no se aman lo que no se conoce
y decidimos salir a mostrar a puerto
sánchez
mostrar su cultura sus tradiciones
entonces organizamos
exposiciones de herramientas de caza y
pesca donde el pescador podía contar
vivencias en el río
y hablar sobre su conocimiento del
comportamiento de las especies
para que utilizara tal o cual
herramienta
y organizamos festivales con músicas y
poesías también acorde a la cultura del
nombre de río
con carrera de canoas
el pescador puede mostrar su destreza en
el río con cursos de mojarreros
hacemos también demostración del final
en marcha las mayas son estas redes que
ustedes pueden ver y que el pescador
utiliza para trabajar en las canchas de
arrastre entonces ahí
la gente que la visitaba por
gracias sobre
nuestra forma de vida nuestra forma de
trabajar
el museo de la costa las procesiones
náuticas
viviente costero
ha resultado de gran atractivo
donde el público puede compartir con
nosotros y conocer más
sobre nuestra idiosincrasia
todo este conocimiento
a sido trasvasados y preservado con
tanto respeto y con tanto cariño es lo
que nos une a los costeros de puerto
sánchez para mantener viva nuestra
cultura
para sostener este nuestro lugar en el
mundo
para preservar el recurso de la pesca y
para eso
le damos estudios a nuestros hijos
y además los capacitamos para trabajar
en el río
y les enseñamos a amar nuestro lugar ese
lugar donde vivimos
nuestro gurises como le decimos aquí en
entre ríos a los niños
sabe jugar a la play
saber manipular una computadora celular
y saben cuál es el mejor juguete
de un gurisito costero
sin duda el mejor juguete sigue siendo
el mojarrero
simple caña con el cielito y un anzuelo
que nos mantiene entretenidos toda la
tarde a orillas del río disfrutando de
la naturaleza sacando mojarritas
estas raíces tan profundas
sentido de pertenencia
son las que hacen
que volvamos a empezar
aun cuando la pesca sea magra cuando las
crecidas del río se lleven todo
el costero vuelve a empezar
por ejemplo
después de la creciente del 2016
cuando puerto sánchez quedó devastado
y su gente
complicada económicamente
nos juntamos los vecinos
y empezamos a realizar ferias de comidas
típicas de pescado
y así
cada uno de los vecinos podía poner
su puestito
necesita sus tablones sus mesas sus
sillas
ofreciendo
especialidades de pescados
logrando así darle valor agregado
al trabajo de la pesca
entonces cada uno podía ofrecer su
especialidad algunas empanadas otro
pescado frito pescado
el principio de los fines de semana y
hoy ya contamos con varios comedores y
quinchos que ofrecen estos sabores
costeros casi todos los días y son de
gran atractivo al turismo
y además generan varios puestos de
trabajo
cuando piensen en puerto sánchez
piensa en la canción
piensen en su paisaje
pero también piensen en su gente
durante cada día
y se esfuerza cada día
sin perder sus raíces
piensen en el pescador
que a pesar unas circunstancias
se levanta cada día y sale al río a
buscar esa carga que le permita darle
bienestar a su familia
que aunque a veces venga con unos pocos
pesos y muchas veces vuelva con las
manos vacías no se rinde
porque cuando pieza tierra firme
no solamente lo espera su familia sino
también espera a sus raíces y si su
abuelo no se rindió
su papá a sus hermanos no se rindieron
él tampoco se rendirá
en su naturaleza está nuestra naturaleza
levantarnos y empezar de nuevo
los invito
a que cada uno piensa en este pescador
en el pescador que cada uno de ustedes
lleva adentro que empuña en sus propios
remos
que salgan cada día a navegar por ese
río de oportunidades que le da la vida
sin perder su naturaleza
sin perder
[Aplausos]